ich habe einen Bauernhof gekauft und im
Juli können wir endlich einziehen es
gibt schon ein paar Beete die die
bisherigen Besitzer angelegt haben und
die haben wir netterweise erlaubt dass
ich jetzt schon ein paar Kartoffeln
pflanzen kann ich will den ganzen
Gemüsegarten noch umstrukturieren weil
ich ganz genau Vorstellungen habe aber
vor Oktober würde ich dazu sowieso nicht
kommen deswegen dachte ich mir pflanze
ich jetzt schon ein paar Kartoffeln in
die freien Beete und dann können wir die
bevor wir den Garten um modellieren noch
ernten der Umzug kriegt jetzt mit jedem
Tag näher und allein die Kartoffeln zu
pflanzen hat das ganze schon viel
greifbarer gemacht aber es ist immer
noch ziemlich unglaublich wenn ich mir
vorstelle dass wir hier in wenigen
Wochen wohnen werden das ist so ein
wunderschöner Ort der Garten ist
unglaublich und ich kann es nicht
abwarten die ganzen Abenteuer zu erleben
die hier auf uns warten